Taylor mattwell show as red States moved
to ban the procedures States like
Minnesota are passing legislation to
declare themselves sanctuaries for child
mutilation one father of a quote-unquote
trans six-year-old testified in favor of
the bill his testimony is being hailed
as heroic and Beautiful by the left but
I have a different take as you might
expect also the College Board makes
changes to its AP African-American
studies course after pushback from
conservatives a BBC correspondent
celebrates the quote beautiful piece of
hand luggage I.E a baby that he had via
the womb that he rented vegan activists
hatch a disastrous plan to shut down a
slaughterhouse in our daily cancellation
we explore the depressing world of
divorce coaches all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you know if you own a business the past
few years have been a bumpy ride from
covid lockdowns to bite inflation you
could probably use a break and
Innovation refunds can help with that if
your business has five or more employees
and manage to survive covid you could be
eligible to receive a payroll tax
treatment of up to twenty six thousand
dollars per employee it's not a loan
there's no payback it is a refund of
your taxes
um The Challenge though is simply just
to get your hands on it how do you how
do you cut through all the red tape and
get your business the refund money that
you're owed and that you deserve well
you got to go to getrefunds.com their
team of tax attorneys are highly trained
in this little-known payroll tax refund
program and have already returned one
billion dollars to businesses and they
can help you do the same they do all the
work no charge up front they simply
share a percentage of the cash that they
get back for you businesses of all types
can qualify including those who took PPP
non-profits and even those that had
increases in sales all could be eligible
for this so if you want to find out more
go to getrefunds.com click on qualify me
and answer a few questions this payroll
tax refund is only available for a
limited amount out of time so don't miss
out go to getrefunds.com that's
getrefunds.com
well as we've been tracking on the show
for years the Republican party did
virtually nothing to fight back against
gender ideology and the transgendas
indoctrination and abuse of children uh
they have been doing virtually nothing
to fight back against it but finally
that has changed and not by accident
those in the anti-gender ideology
movement otherwise known as you know the
sanity movement or the reality movement
whatever term you want to use I've been
in the trenches fighting against this
madness for a long time and it's through
those efforts that we now find ourselves
in a position where States across the
country are passing laws Banning the
mutilation castration and abuse of
gender confused children Utah as we
mentioned yesterday is the is the latest
state to pass a measure Banning medical
transitions on children and that is
significant because it was uh it was
less than a year ago that Utah's
Republican Governor Spencer Cox vetoed a
bill that would have banned males from
female sports and his stated reason was
that he wasn't he said he wasn't in
quote expert on transgenderism and
therefore because he's not an expert on
it all he could do was quote err on the
side of kindness mercy and compassion it
was one of the most shameful episodes of
squishiness we've ever seen from the
squish party and that's saying a lot
Banning males from female sports is uh
it's a layup no pun intended you don't
need to be an expert on anything you
just need to have common sense and
that's how you know that it's the right
move and you don't need you don't even
need political courage to do it because
most Americans agree that Sports should
be segregated based on sex yet Cox went
limp and surrendered anyway now that was
back in March of 2022 so not all that
long ago
fast forward to January 2023 and here he
is signing a bill Banning child gender
transitions he was afraid of being
called a trans folk just a few months
ago now uh he's signing legislation that
had that that will have him labeled a
transphobe by every corporate media
publication in the country all the
people that he was mad that he was uh
worried about being mad at him are going
to be even more mad at him now because
of this so what changed did he somehow
discover a backbone did he undergo his
own gender transition from spineless
jellyfish to actual human man probably
not instead the the political realities
changed
because we forced them to change you and
me those of us who have been speaking
out and fighting back against this trans
Madness we changed the political
Atmosphere by basically force of will
change it so that even a guy like
Spencer Cox has no choice but to do the
right thing and several other states of
course are in line to do the same now on
the federal level the only 2024
candidate officially in the race at this
point Donald Trump announced this week a
series of proposals to eradicate the
trans agenda from schools and doctors
offices and government agencies
Nationwide and we mentioned this briefly
on the show yesterday but it's worth
listening to to some of his proposal as
he outlined it and uh here it is listen
the left-wing gender Insanity being
pushed in our children is an act of
child abuse very simple
here's my plan to stop the chemical
physical and emotional mutilation of our
youth on day one I will revoke Joe
Biden's cruel policies on so-called
gender affirming care ridiculous a
process that includes giving kids
puberty blockers mutating their physical
appearance and ultimately performing
surgery on minor children can you
believe this I will sign a new executive
order instructing every Federal agency
to cease all programs that promote the
concept of sex and gender transition at
any age I will then ask Congress to
permanently stop Federal taxpayer
dollars from being used to promote or
pay for these procedures and pass a law
prohibiting child sexual mutilation in
all 50 states it'll go very quickly I
will declare that any hospital or health
care provider that participates in the
chemical or physical mutilation of minor
youth will no longer meet federal health
and safety standards for Medicaid and
Medicare and will be terminated from the
program immediately furthermore I will
support the creation of a private right
of action for victims to sue doctors who
have unforgivably performed these
procedures on minor children
well it's all very similar to the law
that we're getting passed here in
Tennessee but Tennessee is just one
state we need exactly this we need
exactly this on the national level as
well Trump also says as he goes on to
say that the that he would direct the
Department of Justice to investigate
hospitals pharmaceutical companies of
doctors to find out if they've been
involved in a cover-up of the horrific
long-term side effects uh and of gender
transition drugs and surgeries now the
answer of course is that yes they have
been covering those things up as any
genuine and thorough investigation will
clearly show which is why the next step
under a trump Administration or any
Republican Administration should be to
arrest the culprits the um hundreds and
hundreds of them if not thousands of
them and throw them in federal prison
now this can be a matter of simple fines
and financial penalties I mean that
should be part of it
but uh the only real recourse here the
only semblance of Justice would be
prison sentence is very long ones
now if it were up to me we you know we'd
go further than that as far as I'm
concerned mutilating and castrating
children should be legally considered a
capital crime and it should earn the
prescribed penalty for such crimes but
if we can't have that
then prison will have to suffice
these are all very positive developments
yeah we know that the left isn't going
to take any of this lying down they were
so close in their minds to achieving
their genderless dystopia uh that
they're not going to give up now they
can't because gender ideology is the the
centerpiece of their entire cultural
agenda they can't give up on it they
can't give it up without giving the
whole game away which they're not going
to do and so while red States moved to
protect children from these forms of
physical and sexual abuse blue states
are doubling down on the abuse and doing
everything in their power to ensure that
more and more kids are fed into the
you know transgender wood chipper most
recently the state of Minnesota which is
uh following in the steps of States like
California
has introduced legislation to officially
declare itself a sanctuary state for
Trans kids in other words
Democrats in Minnesota want to traffic
children into the states so they can be
castrated and sterilized these people
are they're not satisfied with simply
butchering the children who already live
in Minnesota they want the state to
become a destination a a hub for such
abuse representative Lee Finke is a man
who says he's a woman and he wrote this
legislation and then explained it on the
house floor this week in Minnesota
listen to this
there are gender diverse people in
Minnesota right now receiving gender
affirming care more are fleeing their
home States asking where they should
turn there are people in the audience
today who have come here for this very
reason
there are doctors in Minnesota right now
providing this world-class gender
affirming care and there are parents who
are terrified about what unknown
consequences may come from Simply
affirming their child's authentic self
this is new law
it's complex and there are questions
that still need to be answered
but we can answer those questions and we
need to do so right now
Utah banned gender affirming care
last Saturday
they were not the first state to do so
and they will not be the last
Tennessee is close behind them
South Dakota is moving
the organized political movement that
has targeted my community is at work in
every state that touches ours
well you're damn right we are we are we
are targeting your community we are and
by your community the community we're
targeting I'm referring to the community
of child abusers of course Finke is
supposed to be seen as an authority here
because he identifies as trans himself
but of course that only makes him less
reliable he has a vested personal
interest in transiting the kids because
it makes him feel better about his own
lifestyle choices which is which is the
motivation for guys like him for Finke
affirming the children quote unquote is
really about affirming himself
and you'll notice this about the vast
majority of the voices speaking up in
favor of transiting the kids most of
them are either alleged medical
professionals who stand to financially
profit from this or they are trans
activists Desperately Seeking
affirmation and validation for their own
self-identities
and on the other side who are the people
on the other side that are that are
speaking out against this well you have
people who don't benefit in any selfish
way at all from the position that we've
taken on this subject we don't make
money on kids who are not trans like we
don't make money on kids who are
protected from the transitive every
child who's protected from the
transgender does not translate into
money for us whereas on the other side
every child who is fed into the trans
agenda and uh claimed by it translates
into money for them and we're also not
seeking any sort of emotional validation
or affirmation of our own lifestyles
we know who we are we we're we're not
worried about that we simply just
believe in defending the truth for the
truth son's sake and we believe in
protecting kids for their own sake
that's it
but back to the other side the debate
over the sanctuary State bill in
Minnesota also featured the testimony of
a father
who claims that his own six-year-old
child is quote trans and this video is
being passed around on social media by
trans activists who say that they were
brought to tears uh by it again it's so
emotional and beautiful they said
um you can listen yourself and tell me
how beautiful you think this actually is
listen
my wife and I are here today
um because we have a trans trans child
actually six years old
at three she was not sleeping very well
she was waking up every single night it
was a lot more than just a toddler
waking up
and one day I picked her up from daycare
and
um
all the teachers had said you
Asher told us that she's the chief
and I said to these wonderful daycare
people who had never had a trans kid
before at a pretty religious place
so what'd you do
and they said we called her for her and
I said great
oh my God great
and Ashley comes around the corner and I
said hey there's my beautiful daughter
and I I I think there are a few things
in this world that are I'll remember for
my whole life and and that is one of
them
the smile on her face the look of
affirmation
the confidence she had to tell her
teachers who had known her since diapers
that she was a she that her father said
there's my beautiful daughter
well speaking of people who should be in
prison there's one there you know I've
I've heard many many testimonies from
parents of young quote trans kids and
I've yet to hear of a single
quote-unquote trans kid
who was acting differently in any
significant way
from any other kid their age
so their father tells us that his son
was waking up in the middle of the night
when he was three
wow that's that's something while a a
toddler isn't sleeping well
who's ever heard of such a thing
this requires uh I mean this requires us
to radically rethink the kids uh very
identity because they're not sleeping
well I mean well you know I I have four
kids three and that are three years or
older or older and um we've actually
gone through the not sleeping well
three-year-old phase with oh I don't
know every single one of them
my six-year-old son when he was three he
he woke up between midnight and 2 A.M
and started playing with his toys or
like walking around the house and he
would do this every night for at least
six months every single night
and I had a lot of thoughts and feelings
about
the fact that he kept waking up and
waking the whole house up
um but I felt many things most of most
of them frustration
but it never occurred to me that he was
waking up because he was tortured by the
thought that he might have been born in
the wrong body that's just that's
something that never crossed my mind and
there are many insane things that never
occurred to me in fact and uh well
that's I guess that's really just only
one of them but it's not simply let's
not sell this father short it's not
simply that young Asher I think his name
was was waking up a lot in the middle of
the night
as toddlers tend to do he also at the
age of three announced himself as a girl
at daycare
um and that's all it took a few
sleepless nights a random declaration
from a toddler and uh that's all this
guy needed his poor son has now been
doomed to a life of confusion identity
crisis despair
eventual medical and surgical mutilation
why is that well because the father
obviously wanted a trans child he wanted
the fashion accessory to carry her
around he wanted his child to become a
vehicle for his own virtue signaling and
he took the first opportunity that came
his way
that's the kind of thing we're fighting
against
while the other side doubles down and
gets more extreme in their evil
we have to double down and become more
extreme in our defense of Truth
and of kids
that's the path forward
and I'm happy to see that it's the path
where finally walking down
now let's get to our headlines
if the past couple of years have taught
us anything it's that in a crisis like a
global pandemic pandemic or a natural
disaster even the basics can be hard to
come by you need to be prepared for
anything and that's why my new partners
at Jace medical are here and they can
help Chase medical helps you get a
long-term supply of prescription
medication their mission is to empower
you to be better medically prepared in
the case a case of any kind of emergency
a great way to start preparing is with
the Jace case a pack of five different
courses of antibiotic by antibiotics
that you can use to treat a whole host
of bacterial illnesses including UTIs
respiratory infections sinuses skin
infections and much more all you have to
do is fill out a simple online form and
in some cases jump on a quick call with
one of their board certified Physicians
from there you can ask your physician
treatment uh related questions on an
ongoing basis and um and you can do all
of this to make sure that you are
prepared in case of of anything as we
said we know that the last couple of
years in particular have shown us
um how important preparedness is
especially if you have have kids the jsk
case gives me peace of mind I can tell
you knowing that my family will have
what we need if the worst happens and I
want you to be prepared for anything as
well all you got to do is go to
jacemedical.com enter code wall should
check out for a discount on your order
that's jacemedical.com promo code Walsh
all right so we'll begin with some news
from apnews.com it says High School
senior uh khalila bendili is used is
used to courses that don't address the
African-American experience
then there's her 9 A.M class this week
it spanned topics from afro-caribbean
migration to Jazz the discussion in her
advanced placement course on
African-American studies touched on
figures from Marcus Garvey Malcolm X to
Jimi Hendrix and Rihanna
uh in her AP European History course she
said we're not discussing black people
at all even though they were colonized
by Europeans
or well that's I mean that that's
shocking to me why aren't they
discussing Rihanna in their European
history course
that I mean this this is that's racism I
can't think of any other reason
why you won't be talking about Rihanna
in your European history course
what about in your astronomy class does
Beyonce ever come up
if not there's racism
says her School in Baton Rouge Louisiana
is one of 60 schools around the country
testing the new course which has gained
national attention since Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis threatened to ban
it in his State the rejection has
stirred new political debate over how
schools teach about race the official
curriculum for the course released
Wednesday by the College Board
downplayed some components that had
drawn criticism from DeSantis and other
conservatives topics including black
lives matter slavery reparations and
queer life are not part of the exam
instead they are included only on a
sample list that states and school
systems can choose from for student
projects
the College Board which oversees AP
exams had revisions to the course were
substantially complete before DeSantis
shared his objections
so that's kind of the headline here that
um
there was this uh new African-American
AP History course
that was devised by the College Board
being rolled out of public schools
across the country and it included a lot
of radical far-left propaganda uh Ron
DeSantis among others
brought that up and was objecting to it
and said that it wasn't going to be
allowed in his State and now the College
Board has revised it and they've
supposedly downplayed a lot of those uh
political elements and but they claim
that oh we were going to do that anyway
we were totally going to do that anyway
it's not because it's not because you
conservatives uh it's not because we're
not caving to backlash from you but of
course they really are
um which is good
you know I I this is something we've
seen in fact more and more recently that
uh backlash from the right actually gets
results and that's uh that is a a new
phenomenon in a lot of ways now that
doesn't mean
that problem solved here or that we
should at all trust this
African-American studies course uh of
course of course we should because it
was always meant to be
a vehicle for far left propaganda that's
what it was always intended to be
and if the course still exists at all
then it is still going to be a vehicle
for our local propaganda even if they
supposedly are
um downplaying certain elements of it
that have drawn objection you know from
the right
it's still there still a propaganda
course I mean why would uh something
like queer life as the AP puts it
or BLM which is a political
scam organization why would that ever be
a part of an African-American studies
program to begin with
well because these programs are
fundamentally ideological
and the the queer stuff in particular
gets shoehorned in
because it is Central to their agenda I
mean everything always comes down to
that on the left every subject
ultimately comes down to an exploration
of gender and sexuality because that is
there on the left that is their their
single preoccupation it's what they care
the most about
and so everything will come down to that
but if we want to get some you know I
think some really insightful analysis of
this debate about African-American
studies and what belongs in school and
what doesn't well I think we should turn
to one place where we turn for
insightful analysis of really any
subject and that is of course the view
um where Whoopi Goldberg had some
thoughts about all this and in
particular about Ron DeSantis and let's
give that a listen
I don't understand why he believes that
he wants people to see the the history
of Western civilization and history and
philosophy of Western Civilization
because he wants to he wants it seemed
through that lens why is your lens
better than my lens
what you know so you're basically saying
like to people like Mary and crook
you're not going to teach about her
because her history is American history
what what is it that he doesn't get
we're not going anywhere
just cause you start teaching it in the
colleges you think people are going to
stop telling these stories you're you're
no it's not going to happen
amen Amen to that utter nonsense
um
of course there's a couple problems here
and uh all stemming from the fact that
Whoopi Goldberg has you know an IQ of uh
. so and she's also a dishonest hack as
well obviously otherwise she wouldn't
but she wouldn't be on that show
but a couple times first she says she
says well African-American history is
American history yeah well right that's
the point that that's actually the point
that's being made by people like Ron
DeSantis and anyone else who objects to
these kinds of courses in public school
we actually we don't need to break
American history down on on racial lines
we don't need to say well let's do the
history of this race and then the
history of this race and the history of
that race
um
let's teach American history which will
Encompass people of different races
nobody ever claimed otherwise
that's our point
to be clear
but then she also seems to suggest that
what DeSantis is really doing and she's
not the only one this is what we're
hearing from the left that um
because DeSantis and other conservatives
are objecting to this radical far left
uh African-American studies of course
what we're really saying is that we
don't want
um black people mentioned in the school
at all we we don't want any of them
mentioned so this you know this is this
is don't say gay 2.0 this is the this is
the don't say gay hysteria uh you know
completely fraudulent phony hysteria
ginned up by the media and this is that
all over again it's don't say gay 2.0
where they took a with don't say gay
bill which is a bill that never existed
they took a bill that really just
protects very young children the school
system from being sexually indoctrinated
by their teachers and then they they
claim that it meant that the word gay is
never allowed to be said anywhere around
the school system and now what they're
claiming is that uh now it's the what is
it this is the don't say black bill I
guess is what they're saying that we're
not allowed to acknowledge black people
at all and they're being erased
from American history uh which is which
is not the case in fact it's what we're
saying is the opposite let's teach
American history the history of this
country and
um and that includes the significant
contributions
of everyone no matter what the race was
um
now it is true and this of course is the
the problem that the left has that uh
well if you teach American history and
you're talking about the significant
contributions made by anyone regardless
of their race
that means that you will be
acknowledging the contributions of lots
of white men too uh that's there'll be
lots of white men
going back to the founding of the
country and uh and ever since then
and that's that is actually their
problem they don't want to have to
acknowledge that
uh Joy Reed also we've already heard
from Whoopi Goldbergs let's throw
joybread in as well she also lashed out
around DeSantis but only made him sound
even better in the process which is
usually the way these things work
here she is
what the scientist is doing is
intentional in order to peel off Trump's
Republican voters and get them on his
side ahead of his presidential bid in
2024. he's turning Florida into a
right-wing Paradise where the focus
isn't on health care or jobs or taxes or
infrastructure I don't know hurricane or
flood insurance in one of the most
natural disaster prone states in the
country you know normal Governor stuff
but rather on the right-wing culture
wars and nothing but the right-wing
culture wars and he's ticking all the
boxes not only is he Banning books about
history and any mention of the existence
of gay people from Florida schools he's
barring public high schools from
teaching AP African-American studies
he's taking aim at drag performances
even suggesting that he would urge the
state's Child Protective Services to
investigate parents who take their own
kids to one
he's actively trying to ban coveted
vaccine mandates and restricting Mass
rules while at the same time calling for
probes into supposed wrongdoing linked
to the vaccine and he's doing all of
this or making sure that anyone can walk
around with a gun no permit required
it's a right-wing Fantasy Land like
Disney World but in Hell come to Florida
the meanest place on Earth
sounds great to me uh of course much of
what she said there's we heard again
there that she's he's Banning any
mention of the existence of gay people
that's total fabrication this is just
what they they make this up and of
course there's never going to be any
fact check or anything like that from
our uh Brave fact-checking organizations
out there but I think this is a really
good this is um
you know this shouldn't necessarily be
your primary motivation as a leader as a
governor but
um it is a pretty good sign that you're
on the right path when someone like Joy
Reed says that this is that you've you
know you're you've turned your state
into a nightmare and you never want to
move there
this is uh you could do worse if you're
trying to figure out what sort of State
what sort of community to build well
build the kind of community
that joy that a person like Joy Reid
would never want to move into
um
and if that if if
that's your path forward if that's kind
of your your Guiding Light
well you could do a lot worse that's for
sure
here's an article from the uh Virginia
pilot says a house of delegates
subcommittee on Monday passed a bill
that would ban transgender girls and
women from competing on female sports
teams at the K-12 schools and
universities delegate Karen Greenhall
who introduced The Measure told at
legislators they had a responsibility to
stand up for female athletes similarly
gifted and trained males will always
have the physical advantage over females
which is the reason we have women's
sports at Green Hall these uh those
opposed to the bill argue that it
discriminated against transgender youth
so we're talking about these kinds of
bills across the country it's also
happening in uh in Virginia but I bring
this up in particular because
of testimony that was offered by
um Riley Gaines she's a recent graduate
from the University of Kentucky
where she had been a member of the
women's swim swim team and she said it
was unfair that she had to compete
against Leah Thomas
who's the male who identified it as
woman and listened to a little bit of
her experience here it is
female swimmers to share a locker room
with Thomas a 6'4 22 year old male who
was fully intact with male genitalia
let me be clear we were not forewarned
we were not asked for our consent we did
not give our consent
if nothing else I hope you can truly see
how this is a violation of our privacy
and how some of us have felt
uncomfortable awkward
um embarrassed and even traumatized by
this experience
I know I don't speak for everyone it's
impossible to speak for everyone but I
can attest to the tears that were shed
on that pool deck by these poor 9th and
17th Place finishers who missed out on
being named an All-American by one place
and I can't attest to the extreme
discomfort in the locker room when you
turn around and there is a male watching
you undress while exposing himself
I can't attest to the anger and
frustration from these girls who had
worked so hard and sacrificed so much to
get to this point
yeah she said she doesn't speak uh for
for everyone and uh well she's right she
doesn't it's as she said it's impossible
to speak for everyone uh they're there
might be
maybe like I'd have to
I I would have to leave open the
theoretical possibility that there might
be some women out there who actually do
want
a man such as Leah Thomas
disrobing in the locker room with them
maybe there are some women out there who
who really are gung-ho about it and say
yeah I want more
I want more uh men parading around the
locker room with their penises hanging
out that's why I want more of that maybe
there are some women out there who
really feel that way I suspect
that if those women exist at all
uh they are very very few and far
between
while you have instead are a bunch of
women you have some women who have
spoken out bravely about this and are
willing to speak out
um many more who have complained about
it privately but haven't spoken out in
public and then and then many more who
have said nothing at all but are
extremely uncomfortable with it and the
reason they haven't said anything is
because they're worried about the
penalties that they'll suffer
um both academic penalties you know the
social consequences and all the rest of
it being shamed as a transphobe and
everything
um
and then there are many more women who
have actually come out in favor of it
verbally
because they think that that's what
they're supposed to do
and they want to show off their virtue
and they want to win those social credit
points
but of course in reality they'd prefer
to have the locker room to themselves so
I think when it comes to locker room
issue in particular those groups that
I've just outlined that probably
encompasses almost all women
um the number of women who are genuinely
excited about the
Prospect the reality of males disroping
in the locker room it's got It's
virtually non-existent
and this has always been you know we
hear about when it comes to Leah Thomas
or any of these males competing against
women
um
much of the conversation focuses around
what's happening in the pool or on the
track or you know what's happening in
the competition and the way that these
these opportunities and medals and
trophies are being taken away from women
and that is a problem it is uh it's a
travesty in many ways
but what's happening in the locker room
is even I mean far worse this is far
more Insidious
that
these women are being forced to endure
this
and being screamed at and told to just
shut up and deal with it while a man
disrobes him from them it is truly truly
evil
and uh and sick
speaking of evil and sick here's a tweet
that's gone
viral over the last past few days
um it's from a correspondent for the BBC
named Mark lowen
and he tweeted this along with a picture
he says after six weeks in wonderful and
tearful uh farewells to our Incredible
or sorry after six weeks in wonderful
Canada it doesn't say Canada there's a
Canadian flag I'm still learning how to
read uh these
hieroglyphic posts where they use
pictures instead of words after six
weeks in wonderful Canada and tearful
farewells to our incredible surrogate
and friend it's time to go home to
Lisbon with our new family member our
most beautiful hand luggage Canada you
are a shining light of democracy and
equality thank you for letting us
fulfill our dream
and then you see the two men there
holding a baby that was uh that was
conceived and birthed via surrogacy
you know we've we've had this
conversation about surrogacy before on
the show and um
as I have been arguing all along
this is a a deeply evil practice this is
the commodification of a children it's a
commodification of a woman's body I mean
the idea that you can rent out a woman's
body
for the purposes of you know growing a
child
that will then and that child will then
be separated
permanently from from his mother
and that you're doing all of this to not
because it's best for the child this is
not being done because it's best for the
child
there's there's no world where it's the
best thing for the child to be conceived
and born via surrogacy and then
separated from his mother forever
that's never in the best interest of the
child
but you're doing it for you to satisfy
your own desires
in fact you hear Mark lowen say it here
thank you for letting us fulfill our
dream
but it's also in this particular case
um this post really jumps out at you
because it's so on the nose
when he refers to the child as hand
luggage
our most beautiful hand luggage
this is something that
you know a real parent
it you you love your child it would you
would never refer to your kid that way
uh you know people might have different
funny sort of ways of of talking about
Parenthood and everything nobody would
no no actual parent would refer to their
their child who's just been born as
beautiful hand luggage
but
that's the way they see it that's that's
what the child is the child is uh is an
accessory for these men
it is totally dehumanizing
to both the child and the woman
um
you know the the commercialized renting
and purchasing of a womb for the
purposes of fulfilling these the the the
quote dreams of these gay men
is uh
incredibly Sinister and wrong but this
is also what you end up with in a
culture where we've decided that the the
ultimate good is the Fulfillment of your
of the individual's own desires like
satisfying the individual's own desires
individual's own ego uh we've decided
that's that's we've structured our
entire culture around
that um we each have our our own
universe that we live in and that
Universe revolves around us and the most
important thing in that universe is how
we feel and affirming our own feelings
and in that kind of situation it's no
surprise that uh
we do things like rent out a woman's
womb so that gay men can grow children
and then separate them forever from
their biological mother in order to
satisfy their own desires all right
finally this video went viral um I don't
know where or when it was taken but it's
apparently from from the way it's being
described it's apparently vegan
activists somewhere who are protesting a
slaughterhouse and their way of protest
in slaughterhouse is to try to stop a
truck from going into the slaughterhouse
they're saying that the the truck has uh
animals in it that are being brought
into their demise and so they want to
stop this huge
truck from going in and they have their
way of attempting to do that which
doesn't work out spoiler alert doesn't
work out too well for them but uh here's
a video
standing here in front of a fearman
slaughterhouse where 10 000 lives are
taken daily ten thousand innocent lives
slaughtered here for no more than the
taste buds of humankind of humans
here we have the truck approaching we're
approximately 300 animals are stacked
into this truck
gonna stop this truck so we can bear
Witness
foreign
geez Jesus
[Applause]
oh I almost got run over
lunatic I'm gonna stop
these drivers have no respect for life
no type of human life no respect for
animal life
psychopath
geez what is wrong with that guy what is
I I'm shell shocked as I I almost got
hurt when I threw myself in front of a
truck
how could that have happened wow jeez
what exactly they are not setting their
best the vegans aren't I don't know if
it's because they're not getting enough
protein in their diet so their brains
are atrophying a little bit uh that's
that does happen that's science so I
don't know if that's what maybe that is
maybe this is their best that's the
thing I keep saying vegan activists and
the stunts that they pull and uh and and
I always assume well this can't be their
best but I think the reality is that
this is this is the best they got so
what exactly was the plan it's you we
see at the beginning that there are
people
on the sides of this uh huge big rig and
they're holding on to the sides of it as
if they think that through that just by
holding it they can stop it from moving
and the truck keeps going and then they
try to throw themselves in front of the
truck and the truck continues on its way
and I don't think the truck actually did
run anybody anybody over
uh thankfully for the vegans
but if you have that would have been
their fault you throw yourself in front
of a truck
that's on you
and by the way you know when you've got
even if they are uh a bunch of newly
armed vegans even so when you have
people uh mobs of people trying to stop
your car in the middle of the road
um you the safest thing is to keep going
because we've seen what happens in the
past when you stop for these people you
get pulled out of the truck you never
know what will happen
so for your own safety
and also for the safety of that of that
precious cargo in the back
on its way to the slaughterhouse
and for all the the rest of the sake of
all the rest of us who want to enjoy
that delicious bacon you have no choice
but to continue going I think all right
let's get to the comment section
and it's required that you grow a beard
hey we're the sweet baby gang
whether you've quit your New Year's
resolution or you're still going strong
it's never too late to start paying off
those credit cards if one of your goals
is to take control of your credit card
debt which is a great goal to have well
then you need to check out light stream
a credit card consolidation from
lightstream can help you pay off your
credit cards and it can lock in a low
fixed interest rate rates start at 7.99
APR with autopay and excellent credit
plus the rate is fixed so it will never
increase over the life of the loan you
get a loan from five thousand dollars to
a hundred thousand dollars without any
fees at all you can even get your money
as soon as the day you apply lightstream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience and
that's exactly what they deliver to uh
to everybody and just for my listeners
you can apply now to get a special
interest rate discount and you could
save even more at the same time the only
way to get this discount is to go to
lightstream.com
Walsh subject credit approval rates
range from 7.99 APR to 23.99 APR include
point five percent auto pay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply offers our
subjects change without notice visit
lightstream.com Walsh for more
information
Jessica says I think he should have made
the gender cake I understand and agree
with him about not customizing a gay
marriage cake but the gender cake was
not customized both the customer and the
baker were acting out of hate
that's been brewing
how is it hate on the part of the baker
yeah you're right about the customer
acting on the uh out hate trying to
entrap Jack Phillips I'm trying to
intentionally put him in a position so
that he can be sued
so yes he's acting out of hate there
but
uh the baker just doesn't want to be a
part of any kind of celebration of a
quote unquote gender transition
because that would be to participate in
a lie for one thing
and it's a celebration of self-harm and
self-mutilation and a lot of terrible
things
the baker says I don't want to be I
don't want to be a part of it you can't
force me to be a part of that I don't
want to be a part of that event
and just because I've opened a bakery
this small town Bakery doesn't mean that
I'm required to be a part of any event
that someone demands I I participate in
so no he's just as Justified and not
wanting to make the quote-unquote gender
transition cake as not wanting to
customize the gay wedding cake
this is not only freedom of speech this
is a this is a fundamental case of
freedom of Association you should not be
forced to associate yourself with an
event
that uh you find morally abhorrent
for whatever your reasons are it doesn't
matter
and this doesn't need to be grounded
especially the gender transition thing
yeah Jack Phillips is a Christian but
this is not this is really something to
do with religious liberty necessarily
yeah it would be it would be immoral
according to the Christian faith to
participate in an evil event like that
but you don't need to be a Christian
to see uh the the problem with you know
the concept of gender transition and
celebrating it with a cake
so this is basic free speech freedom of
Association and that's it
and you know
at the same time
if this person really just wanted the
cake for this celebration
uh uh he could have just said I'd like a
pink cake with blue icing and he could
have said that and he would have got
that because because Jack Phillips would
not if you ever you know any Baker
you've ever been to they don't demand
details on the kind of ceremony that
you're celebrating
now if you offer it because you want the
cake customized for like a birthday then
yeah but uh if you just go in there say
I want this cake they're not going to
make you fill out a questionnaire with a
bunch of uh information about the type
of event and that didn't happen here
that information was volunteered
and then Jack Phillips said well now
that you've told me that
um and you've given me that information
unsolicited now I have to respond
accordingly
actual final boss says I can't believe
the media continues to misgender Matt as
a blogger he's clearly a vlogger
thank you very much that is what I
identify as
um
Kristen Funk says we need Matt to do a
segment on Velma nothing I want to see
more than Matt put Mindy Kaling to task
uh I I'm only even vaguely aware of the
so I know that people are upset about
Velma Velma is what is it the Netflix or
maybe it's HBO Max something like that
one of the streaming services
did a spin-off of Scooby-Doo it's a
cartoon and in the spin-off number one
I mean the first problem is that from
what I've been told
um Scooby-Doo is is not even featured at
all in this the show so they've taken
Scooby-Doo out and it also focuses
around Velma who's like a lesbian and
genderqueer or whatever and they put a
bunch of woke uh stuff into it and all
the rest of it
um and they've also made this a cartoon
that's targeted supposedly towards you
know adults
although I'm sure there are plenty of
kids watching it
um
that's all I know about it I really have
nothing interesting to say about it
other than this is
yet more evidence of the fact that all
we get from Hollywood is a is a bunch of
garbage
um
and like even if it was you know what
even if it was a faithful spin-off of
Scooby-Doo I would object to it even
without I mean with all the woke stuff
that's
disgusting and and abhorrent and uh it
doesn't belong in a cartoon especially
because even if they claim it's targeted
towards older people it's still you're
still gonna end up with kids watching it
so that doesn't belong there but um even
without that like do we need another
do you have all these franchises with a
million spin-offs and everything was
there ever that much meat on the bone to
begin with you take something like
Scooby-Doo you know it was a it was a
vaguely amusing cartoon came out decades
ago there was never that much meat on
the bone there's no there's not enough
content there to support a decades-long
franchise with films and uh spin-offs
and different shows and everything
just let it rest Let It Go
uh
and Rodrigo says I have to disagree
about your anxiety rant while I agree
the teacher didn't manage the situation
the best way anxiety or more uh
specifically chronic anxiety is a mental
disorder while normal anxiety has a
clear and reasonable reason for it and
if that reason disappears the anxiety
disappears
chronic anxiety does not have any of
that while normal anxiety is like fear
an alarm that signals something
stressful chronic anxiety is like a
phobia a broken alarm that needs to be
fixed but I kind of agree that not all
problems like this should be fixed with
drugs you don't understand all the brain
still so a lot of drugs affect the in
other ways we still don't understand
fully that's a problem in the over
medicated Society in the U.S
okay yeah I understand that you you are
laying out the uh the assertions that
are made in favor of treating uh anxiety
as a medical condition and in favor of
inventing this uh illness called anxiety
disorder so you you have you have yes
you have I think correctly laid out the
series of assertions That's supposed to
support that but these are not arguments
these are just this is just an assertion
um and you haven't
addressed any of
the actual problems that this raises
so to begin with
well you know you have anxiety that
exists uh for a good reason and then you
have anxiety that exists for uh for not
a good reason well who who determines
first of all who determines what is a an
appropriate reason to feel anxiety
who who exactly is in a position
well psychiatrists and the medical
industry they decided
why do they get to decide that how are
they experts
in in what are good reasons and
reasonable reasons to feel anxious
here here's a list of reasons why you
should feel anxious if you're anxious
for these reasons you shouldn't feel
anxious and that's an illness
do you not see how totally arbitrary
that is
are we not supposed to sit back and say
well who where are you getting this from
why are you the authority on this just
because you have doctor in front of your
name does that that makes you an expert
on something as
on a question as
as big as you know what are the
appropriate reasons to feel anxiety
so who
why do they get to determine that what
are they basing those determinations on
and also even if we could all agree I
don't know by majority vote or some
democratic process that uh there are you
know
there there are unreasonable anxieties
that people feel
well that in and of itself doesn't prove
that it's an illness
you know maybe there are unreasonable
anxieties I think that there are sure
but maybe that's also part of being a
human being is to experience
unreasonable anxieties
and here's another question too
and I and I you know I've made the same
point about depression and
I think it's the case of with anxiety as
well
and this is something people don't like
to to just the possibility people don't
like to think about okay but what if
you know if you're feeling anxious
and you can't identify an exact reason
for it
what if life itself
is a reason to be anxious what if simply
existing as a mortal human being
is reason enough
to feel anxiety
just like with depression what if there
are just realities about our The Human
Condition
that can sometimes cause people to feel
despair now that doesn't mean that you
should feel anxious all the time or you
should be in disparable time obviously
you shouldn't it also doesn't mean that
you shouldn't look for for help if
you're struggling with these feelings
I'm not saying that either
all I'm saying is that uh maybe people
who are feeling depressed or feeling
anxious
they're not like diseased and they're
not even being unreasonable
it's just it's it is it is tough to
exist as a human being there are many
things about life that create anxiety
let's start with the reality of death I
mean the fact that death hovers over all
of us all the time and we know that
eventually it will come and claim us and
we will cease to exist in the Physical
Realm I mean that alone is something
that can make people feel anxious and
you can feel anxious about that anytime
and uh but it might be in a kind of
ambiguous amorphous way where you don't
really understand where the feelings are
rooted from but maybe that's part of it
I mean
um
so maybe these are things that come with
the Human Condition which again just
because something is uh
fundamental to The Human Condition it
doesn't mean that we shouldn't do
anything to
um help ourselves you know deal with
those realities but it does mean that
just labeling it a disease
and trying to solve the problem with a
pill
might not be
you know the the best approach
and certainly might not get to the root
of the problem
you know this weekend uh you probably
didn't know because I just learned in
this moment right now is the Grammys and
if you're a true member of the SPG
you're aware of the outsized share of
influence pop culture has on my life I
am a pop culture
fanatic everyone says that about me
although my Affinity for televised award
ceremonies is widely recognized it's my
notorious status as a rap Mogul that
gives this award show truly venerable
significance in the sweet baby gang I
peruse the nominees and sadly
um I wasn't among them probably because
I don't have anything that could
possibly be nominated for but still it's
a grave Injustice
um that uh my hip-hop forefathers push
iced tea and spot em got em have also
endured and now I'm experiencing the
same thing all this to say I'm proud to
announce the newest sweet baby album
t-shirt which is which I have uh with me
right now it is hopefully you can see
this in there thanks
it is the notorious SBG and uh the great
thing is that this is not a copyrighted
violation we did check with our lawyers
this latest addition to my swag Shack
over the daily wire.com is available
right now and uh you don't want to miss
out on this opportunity to
confuse people culturally appropriate at
the same time experience the
immortalization of both my prominence
and the hip-hop world and lyrical
prowess in the form of yet another
instant classic we saw enough of these I
very well may have to spit bars for the
game are you no I'm not going to make
I'm not gonna have another promise I
don't keep cut that I'm not doing that
that's I will not even pretend that I'm
going to do that
anyway go to dailywire.com shop to get
your notorious SPG t-shirt now also
we've been running a massive 40 off sale
for annual memberships and it ends
tomorrow don't miss the chance to
celebrate one of the greatest moments in
Daily wire history with one of the
greatest offers when you join you get
access to the best content one of the
fastest growing libraries writing a ton
of new content this year with kids uh
content uh more movies and shows hard
hitting documentaries I much more
remember this is your last chance to get
40 off your annual memberships
dailywire.com subscribe with code do not
comply the sale ends tomorrow so head to
dailywire.com subscribe right now now
let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
Wednesdays for our members block portion
of the show I answer emails from
listeners looking for advice and I also
sometimes issue corrections to the bad
advice offered by people on other forms
especially uh Tick Tock and the bad
advice videos are curated by my producer
McKenna and sent to me at which point I
uh go through them all and that's when I
become depressed and disgusted and the
light inside me dies a little more but
at least it makes good content and
that's how the creative process works
but yesterday uh I was sent one bad
advice video that is so bad in which I
found so viscerally abhorrent and
repulsive that it immediately graduated
from Members Blackwater to the Daily
cancellation this of course is the
greatest honor I can bestow on a
terrible person and we have a very
terrible person for today's second
Jessica Ashley builds herself as a
divorce coach this is apparently an
actual industry that exists in our
country after a brief Google search I
discovered there are many divorce
coaches and divorce Consultants charging
exorbitant hourly rates to encourage and
facilitate the dissolution of marriages
um divorce coaches
should not be confused with divorce
lawyers these are two different species
of blood sucking parasites think of one
as kind of like a deer tick and the
other is a dog tick and even the ticks
have ticks as there are now many pricey
online certification programs offered
for those who want to become certified
in the field of divorce coaching so if
you wish to be a certified a certifier
of a certified divorce coach then you
get then you have to do that if you want
to be a certifier of people who are
certifying divorce coaches there are
probably different programs for that
and if you want to coach people who
certify the people who certify the
people who are divorce coaches again
there is I assume a program for that one
thing we've learned about the modern
modern culture is that for every evil
for every brand of misery there are a
million vultures circling looking for a
way to make a fast Buck on someone
else's poor life choices in fact there
is so much misery and so many soulless
profiteers trying to monetize it that it
becomes a kind of parasitic infinite
regress
and somewhere in this garbage heap lies
Jessica Ashley who offers three-month
and six-month divorce subscription
Services uh she's also on call by the
way ready for her phone or FaceTime
consultations for anyone desperate and
stupid enough to pay the money for it
and sorry fellas I got to tell you she
does stipulate that she is a divorce
coach for moms specifically her website
tagline is a mom's best girlfriend in
divorce
though I strongly suspect that the
market for divorce coaches consists
almost entirely of women anyway it's
like if the Cupcake Wine Company
stipulated that it was just for women
you know it's already kind of implied by
the nature of the product
but uh Jessica has developed a
relatively sizable social media
following consisting entirely of the
sorts of women who have been you know
would have been probably tried and
convicted of Witchcraft if they'd been
born in a different era uh these are
women who who can't get enough of this
kind of stuff listen
the very best piece of advice I've ever
received about divorce came in the early
days of my own divorce from a friend
who'd never been divorced and in fact
wasn't even married at the time she said
something so powerful it really got in
there and it still Rings true today and
I share it with my divorce coaching
clients often here's the best piece of
divorce advice I've ever heard your life
is bigger than one man let's extend it
your life is bigger than one
relationship one marriage One Moment In
Time even if that relationship comes
with good intentions and Oodles of love
and Big Dreams in a home and kids and
memories and vacations what happens if
you release your grasp that this
relationship defines the whole of you
and the whole of your life to see what
could come next what is happening now
there was a time before this
relationship you are heading into the
next part what are the possibilities
that extend far beyond this one person
now the people in the comments section
are absolutely Blown Away by these
platitudes that Jessica plagiarized from
the slogans on inspirational keychains
at a gift shop somewhere she's like some
kind of feminist bumper sticker and yet
many of the commenters claimed that they
were reduced to Tears by Jessica's
recitation of modernist cliches one
woman said that the video had saved her
life
which is which is like having your life
saved by a fortune cookie worst of all
the cliches aren't true because if you
are betraying your vows and dismantling
your marriage and running out on your
husband and hurting your children in
pursuit of your own personal happiness
you are not bigger than the moment um
there are moments in life that make us
who we are moments that tell us and tell
the world who we really are and if
you're following Jessica Ashley's advice
then you will answer that moment by
announcing yourself to be a disloyal
self-centered shallow superficial
narcissist you were not bigger than the
moment you are defined by it the whole
point of marriage is that two become one
and when you say I do to your spouse you
are entering into something that is
bigger than you and from this Union
Springs a family and children and a
whole life that you could never live on
your own you're not bigger than that
if you shrink away from that commitment
that that's uh that sacred institution
that you've entered into it's not
because you're bigger than it but
because you are smaller than it you are
too small too Hollow to grasp with
happiness that can be found in loyalty
and Fidelity to your family
in the same way if you visit the Sistine
Chapel and you find that you're bored or
unimpressed by the site it's not because
you're too significant or too big to
appreciate it right that's because
you're you're such a small-minded
brain-dead idiot that you can't
recognize Beauty when you're standing in
his presence
that's why none of the divorced cat
ladies who pay Jessica for consultations
will go on to achieve great things or
contribute to the world in any important
way
none of them will
now they say that they're getting
they're divorced and they're free now
and they can go out into the world and
do all these impressive things they're
not going to do anything instead they'll
wind up dating a bunch of pathetic men
desperate enough to see them as romantic
options and they'll argue with their
ex-husbands and they'll watch a lot of
TV and they'll be promoted to middle
management and they'll make you know 140
000 a year and they'll feel very
accomplished and they'll spend their
money on consumer products and cat food
and they'll tell themselves a story
about the journey they've been on but
that Journey will be about as
interesting and unique as a Hallmark
greeting card less interesting actually
because at least a Hallmark card is
something that you buy to Express
gratitude towards some other person in
your life
but the women who listen to Jessica
Ashley are far more focused on
expressing gratitude towards themselves
they are collapsing into themselves
sucked into the Vortex of their own egos
the human equivalent of dying Stars
slowly evolving into black holes
except that you know entire galaxies
really do revolve around actual black
holes in the case of these women that's
how they see themselves but it's not the
reality
now Jessica has more wisdom to offer
though in another video she tries to
explain why men might change during the
course of a marriage here's her Theory
have you ever asked why your husband is
radically changed why he seems like a
completely different person than he was
in the early days of marriage before
kids or maybe even before you got
married have you look back over the last
few years with a fine tooth comb and
everything said and done looking for the
perfect clue an incident or event that
will help bring rationale to why he has
turned so hateful in his words in action
When you entered into this Union with
such love have you desperately sought
out the perfect things for you to say or
do that will get this marriage back on
track that will get him back on track
that will maybe be the Cure marriage
counseling or Couples Retreat or maybe a
change in meds now certainly trauma
grief mental health issues illness
injury so many things can cause us to be
an acts totally differently but
sometimes people's masks get too heavy
and they fall off and they reveal who
they really are
now sure okay that might be true in some
cases there are some men who essentially
dupe their wives into marriage
sociopaths Who hide their true nature
their true selves uh there are women who
do this also you know that that can
happen in a marriage but if you're a
woman
whose husband seems to have grown
miserable and angry during the course of
your marriage
you should also consider
the very real possibility that he has
become that sort of man
in response to the sort of woman you are
um you should at least consider that
possibility that is a that is a
potential
explanation that you must take into
account
and if you're the sort of woman who is
inclined to seek counsel from a cliche
spewing divorce coach on Tick Tock it
seems rather likely that you're
miserable angry quote hateful husband
has been broken down by years spent
trying to please these shallow
egotistical when she married again I'm
obviously not saying this is always the
case I'm simply saying that it's a
possibility you have to take into
consideration
because as men you know we very much
want our wives to support us to be proud
of us
um we might not express that desire out
loud in fact we probably will never say
that we aren't generally generally very
Adept at vocalizing those kinds of
emotions and desires but when a man
comes home from his from work and you
know his wife gives him a kiss and says
hi honey I'm so glad you're home or you
know when his wife comes up to him at
the blue and says that she's she's proud
of him and grateful for how hard he
works
um
something like that that man will
immediately be on cloud nine you will
feel appreciated and respected and loved
this is what women need to understand
about men you don't need to give us
very much to make us happy we just need
your affection we and and we'll never
tell you that we'll never verbalize it
but that's what we need that's what we
want we actually want to feel
appreciated and loved
by our wives if you can believe it
that's that's something that men in a
marriage really want
um
let me let me give you let me give you a
secret here's the cheat code this is
what every man wants okay this is this
is how you make him happy
he wants to walk in the door after work
and his children run up to him and say
hi Daddy and they give him a hug and his
wife comes over and smiles and kisses
him dinner's on the stove everyone is
happy and glad to see him I mean and
that's all it really is as simple as
that
that's that's if a man has that he has
almost everything he needs in the world
of course not it can't be like that
every day and every family is different
every situation is different uh you
might be a situation where maybe both
spouses have to work especially in this
economy uh maybe the man Works a
different shift so he's not really
coming home at dinner time anyway my
point is simply to convey to you how
easy it is to make a man happy how
simple our desires actually are
how comparatively little we actually
want
um how love and affection and gratitude
are the things that we really need in
our marriage
so if your husband seems bitter and
angry
you might consider whether you have
given him any of those things
anytime recently or at all
or you could just assume that he's a
sociopathic monster who is wearing a
mask and only let it slip after years of
marriage that could be the case
but if you assume it's the case
there's probably a rather self-serving
reason for that
that's what divorce coach Jessica Ashley
isn't going to tell you and it's why she
is today canceled
and that'll do it for us today
um and uh we'll talk to you tomorrow
have a great day Godspeed
[Music]
president Trump proposes Banning
transgenderism entirely Rhonda santis
wins a victory in the classroom and
Bernie Sanders charges 95 bucks to whine
about capitalism check it out on the
Michael Knowles show
foreign